so freunde da sind wir zurück in der
tagesschau nicht erst mal dieses leimen
und ich erstmal auf gebackene kartoffeln
am 9
da hast du von mir haben gegebene hasse
wehrmacht direkt neues thema wenn ich
hier die xp fall jetzt bauen wir auf den
dschungel suche seite leute ich und zwar
kommt das von ferdinand niemand eine
woche ohne internet für euch machbar für
mich momentan ist die situation nicht
also wird zu sagen dir also aufgegangen
freut sich zwar nicht an das salz weil
wir jetzt ganz langweilig sagen uns dann
ja dann ist auch eine woche oder zwei
wochen urlaub haben auch im internet
nahmen langsam aber ich nehme jetzt mal
die situation an die er wahrscheinlich
meint dass man wirklich spontan internet
ausfall hat oder so das wäre echt
momentan sehr ungünstig aber ich einmal
so ein monat ohne internet dass das geht
noch locker durch aber wenn es
irgendwann so monat ist oder so als dann
irgendwann schon krank ab sodass also
nach sehr sinnvoll den erste wenn ich
hab gesagt nur mal so eine woche jamie
oliver sohn monat das geht schon klar
beim monat ist schon zuviel eine woche
meine ich das ist halt eine woche bis
gar kein wo ich mein mann ist ja im
urlaub oder im internet bist kein ding
für king aber aber jetzt so ein monat
vor allem was irgendwie unangekündigt
ist und ich finde einfach keine sonnig
verlängerung wo läufst du denn auch
lange du hast du denn da lang ja du
läufst wieder komplett falsche richtung
wie sie sich als journalist du läufst
einfach falsch läuft auf einmal rechts
ab der täter schützt du dir ich tippe
ich nicht ich hab ja von h&m aktion
aufgefunden ich habe jetzt ein wenig ab
das heißt ich weiß ich werde
wahrscheinlich niemals niemals märz den
weg zurückfinden nebels nicht opfer
egal erste banken holen und holz ich
bereue es für alles eine
gemeinschaftliche falle hier dann kriegt
man auch weil er weil irgendwann müssen
wir noch einen drachen eigentlich mal
bekämpfen wettkämpfen
da müssen auch alle einladen die jeweils
dabei waren riesige in rage um richtig
von mir einfach richtig einfach näher
dran zu siegen ich habe von sogar schon
zu einfach sein für euch da draußen
vorbei
noch schwächer oder rüstung gehen das
kannst du nicht machen auch immer weiter
man beim abholzen
ich wünsche dir dass du da bist du wie
viele level hast du ich hab ein turnier
basta
bei mir geht die sonne durch ein mensch
sehr gut dass er sie produktiv es
wenigstens im gegensatz zu anderen
gästen was ist halt im dschungel gerade
oder was den aufbau wird simon und er
fällt alles ab was ihr ist wir vergleich
unter simon
das finde ich das sehr platt als
startseite abfällen sie mal auf du
kannst jetzt richtig simon sasse verfügt
das letzte nicht machen sollen
ich bin ich zu dir wie du würde ich hier
nicht gibt ja ich hab ich ja kein level
mehr
die pds ist obst im haus und jetzt
diskutiert wird die zweite online etc wo
sind jetzt meine sachen wo wenig unter
dem slogan ich hab schon so viel
eingesammelt alles ist da wo ich gucke
ich mir ganz sachen finden da ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich hier eine falle brand
so blöd so trug mal sehen ob ich denn
jetzt noch kein nicht nur eine szene und
eichenlaub voll doch einfach hier diesen
baum ob hatte hier ich helfe dir als
entschädigung sollte stellt runter und
warte einfach ich glaube jetzt wieder
zurück nicht an den weg irgendwie ja
manchmal hast du gewonnen oder so
nein ich komme nicht mehr zurück und es
wird dunkel könnte nach doch nicht
schlafen dann können wir nicht missen
so durchkommen dennoch biss
direkt angeschlossen der op zum sterben
du bist gar nicht bist du ach man direkt
an die halle zu bauen
der mond es ist kein fall mut fasst
wohingegen das wasser hier zu sein mikro
von der rand voll und die stimmung
dramatisch dazu erscheinen zu lassen
es ist dunkel ich bin allein im
dschungel verloren
ich weiß nicht wohin ich weiß nicht
woher ich kam
ich weine der ewige schlucht in einer
höhle sieg richtig episch aus ich habe
einen traum als jetzt noch drei andere
topstars auf breite wenig großen events
komplett unwahr
wenn es letztlich auch egal wie viel du
hast
am mikrofon so ein bisschen hier vor
mich halten so jetzt ist der feste
arbeit dafür kann ich jetzt zu tun als
wäre ich ein richtiger erzähler
es war gar nicht viel kaffee kaffee
erzählt eine kalte sommernacht
im dschungel um herum nur bäume das
wetter das postbote erwartet so viele
dinge noch mehr sitzen auch jörg asmus
aufsetzen infektionen geräuschlos ihr
euch ein bisschen höher stellen machte
geht's los für die kreaturen der nacht
die kombi aus dem dickicht des waldes
das geschehen was ist nur passiert
als allein allein allein allein auf der
einfluss gar nicht so schlimme sache die
eisige finsternis auf der anderen seite
der tödliche dschungel
was kann ich tun gerade eigentlich nur
holz oder was bleibt mir das ist gerade
nur halt mit schnauze da auf der suche
nach noch mehr holz ja immer tiefer in
die losen schafft noch mehr holz und
noch mehr als ich sah den wald voller
reichte dem mond gut das heißt ich bin
nach draußen finden in seinem riesigen
ozean
ich sehe nur blaue ich bin irgendwo
unter wasser da ist die decke des
wassers wenn draußen ja geil ich bin in
motion
ich hab kein pardon ich bin denen er
sagt mir bitte die koordinaten unser
haus ist weil ich bin gerade im kräften
er trug f3 bis jetzt richtig krachen
okay es ist nummero xtm nach darwin - 60
bei ickx und ungefähr 230
okay da mussten wir in diese richtung
laufen auch deine unterstufe die nacht
deswegen ungefähr 000 ist immer wichtig
um ungespielt halten es eigentlich immer
so
sag mal ich hätte mein name der stimme
die eines den ausgleich wo kommen sie
her
so geht sie hin fragen über fragen was
eine riesige schlucht
übrigens nicht mit versprechen
hallo ich bin's wieder an ich sah das
erste mal dass die kreatur der
finsternis
ich hatte noch eine entscheidung
richtigen tür übergangen oder laufen
ich würde mein herz mein herz schlug mir
bis zum halse die klasse der finsternis
die schau durch an der erbitterte kampf
der kampf erst rückte der kampf um die
beide haben auf mich ein
und ich gewinne kampf da kam noch mehr
ein zombie eine kreatur
ich würde gern ich gerne mehr simon sein
dass bestimmte total unspektakulär noch
einmal erleben ja
dreileben kartoffeln geben doppelt acht
milliarden auf einmal mein herz junge
rein
dort war ich sicher versteckt zwischen
dem dickicht des waldes zwischen den
schatten der bäume die kreaturen die
kreaturen sammelten sich
okay wir haben wir haben es geschafft
wir haben überlebt doch die nacht ist
noch nicht vorbei es kann jederzeit
wieder zu einem angriff kommen
ich hab' ich hab vergessen wo ich diese
bäume gefällt habe demnach fehlen jetzt
diese ganzen setzlinge nein so was du
bist aber ich habe einen neuen baum
kommen mir echt ist schon ja warte ich
komme bei dir vorbei wissen eine falle
import shop mediahaus dann kommt dann
verwenden wer das cockpit bei nicht
gerade wenig speicherplatz auf q
das heißt wie viele festplatte denn
heute müssen wir ganz kurz muss auch mal
ganzen cut machen und dann mache ich
ganz kurz meine speichern ein
speichermedium auf feste set das sagen
was man will was ist wenn ihr noch eine
festplatte das was hat die für
buchstaben kann wieder bei 1 1 oder so
was von langweilig eine lokal facto von
dlf alle funktioniere ich meine jetzt
nicht besonders spektakulär ist um
irgendwie ich renne ich im dschungel
fällt bäume aber ich hatte auch darauf
zu warten dass dieses sei
ich muss mein diamant schwerter ich hier
und gewerbe mit jane austen ekelhaft
stimmt kann ich jetzt die nummer auf
englisch immer ein paar mal ich hab mich
die ganze zeit rund um die comic
einsetzt etwas abgekürzt bei mir
ich höre die penan ich bin das ist sehr
witzig gerade
ich glaube das liegt einfach an erst
bestimmt den us internet er tipps ich
war es cool
wir warten einfach mal ganz kurz nach
den er zwischen können wenige andere
welt gehen und in oslo willkürlich
zeugen oder wir warten halt ein wenig
ganz kurzen schlucken wunderschönes
wetter draußen die sonne scheint aber
zum aufnehmen natürlich gerade relativ
suboptimal weil die sonne wirklich
einfach so direkt in mein gesicht
erscheint mit wegen
kann ich das nicht so richtig erkennen
was hier auf dem bildschirm abläuft und
roh
dabei geht jetzt überhaupt noch
irgendwas
entschuldigung
aufgelegt cool
würd gern mal auf online genius passt
entschuldigung dürfte später umgehen
m
ja keine ahnung will wohl grad nicht
er will wohl nicht
freunde internet ist komplett weg ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns im nächsten
partner